all right
hello everyone I'm Joel Francis I want
to make all software from all time
instantly available for use by any
programmer and here with me
hey everybody I'm Adam Smith from UC
Santa Cruz and among many other things I
want to make a new kind of search engine
that looks within and across the
contents of interactive media like apps
and video games
so let's go back in time to the
mid-1850s and talk about Alice in
Wonderland
so who here has heard of the phrase of
falling down the rabbit hole
this is where it comes from so this is a
copy of the book Alice in Wonderland in
the Library of Congress and what you see
highlighted here on the screen is the
section of that text that talks about
that moment in Alice in Wonderland
so this is something that we're all
familiar with quoting text and this is
what we can do if we want to remember a
particular part of a of a work if we
want to compare that work with other
texts
and this portion of the text is about
two and a half percent of the total work
similarly if you watch that moment in
the Disney movie this is that same
moment we're all familiar with getting a
clip of a movie if you're taking a media
studies class this might be something
that a professor would assign to you you
can use Clips to compare different works
with each other so there are a lot of
stage Productions of Alice in Wonderland
and if you wanted to compare and
contrast this moment this is what you
could do you could have a clip of of a
movie
but what about video games
how do you quote video games
like really take take a moment to think
about it
all right well
you can do a gameplay video where you
can watch somebody playing through a
video this is a moment here from the
Game Boy game Alice in Wonderland it's
the same moment of Alice going down the
rabbit hole but this clip itself
um just this clip if we were to trim
trim this out it's four times larger
than the entire ROM so in terms of space
it's not that great because it's much
bigger than the original work it's not
even interactive yeah you can't get a
feel for what this is like so
what can we do about that well
um here we have a playable quote so this
is that same moment of the game but it
is uh only about five percent of the
original ROM
and if we click on it here
you can see it's looks similar to that
uh that video that we were watching but
there's there's something new here where
I can take over control
and now here I can go the left I can go
to the right I can slow down I can speed
up and so now I really have a feel for
what is happening in this game
so here is a playable quote
um
close that off
so to Briefly summarize we've talked
about how you can quote text this is
something that we're all familiar with
we can quote video
talked about the limitations of of game
video and introduced the idea of a
playable quote but what is a playable
quote
so this is what we're going to be
talking about today
um in the research that Adam and I have
done on playable quotes we've identified
the four areas that you see here on the
screen so in terms of playability you've
already seen that you've saw me interact
with that game quote and I was playing
it we also saw this aspect where it's
performative so before I took over
control you were seeing the original
gameplay of when I first recorded that
quote about a month ago you saw you know
it was moving back and forth and so
you've got an idea of of what you should
do in that moment in the game
but there's two more aspects that we
haven't covered so this there's this
idea of a quote should be partitioned it
should be a smaller piece of the
original work similar to how a a clip of
you know a quote of text is smaller than
the original work a clip of a movie is
smaller and it should also be permanent
something that you can use not just for
this particular moment in time because
you know just you know it's not
dependent on a particular version of a
Linux kernel with a particular uh
version of an emulator it should be
something that you can use 10 years 100
years into the future think about it
like maybe if the original game was lost
we want the quote to still be playable
that way we could have
well we'll get into it later yeah
so let's talk about this partition so uh
how who here has seen blackout poetry
before
um blackout poetry uh for those of you
haven't seen it is this really neat way
of writing a poem using an existing
piece of text and you will literally go
and black out all the text that you
don't want and leave just the parts that
you want and that's a really good
analogy for what we're doing when we
partition a quote so that game that you
just saw me play that quote of Alice in
Wonderland is visualized here next to
that blackout poetry this is a
visualization of only the parts of the
ROM that were needed for that particular
moment in the game so all of the big
black empty pixels that's those are all
zeros so we literally recorded or or
traced what was happening during
gameplay
made a list of only those Those portions
of the ROM that were used and then we
zeroed everything else out and this is
what it looks like when you visualize it
so the little colored bits those are the
color value more or less maps to the to
the value of that byte and so you can
think of one way of thinking about what
we've what we've done is a part of a
quote is this Mass ROM which has been
you know emptied out of everything
except for just what's needed for that
portion of of of the the game
another way to think about it is this
visualization here so here on the left
with the white background you see a
gameplay of Tetris and then here on the
right with this dark background you can
see the memory accesses happening so
you'll see little things flashing but
you'll note that in this portion of
gameplay there's only a kind of a fixed
portion of of the ROM that's actually
being used and all the rest is never
really used either so this is another
way of thinking about like what is
actually going on when you're recording
a quote
so here's yet another way of of looking
at this so
let me explain here what we've got on
this on this this here so on the top row
this is roughly what the screen was
looking like at that moment in time
this row here second from the top is
showing basically the the average pixels
per row so what it looks like here is
your what it's visualizing is you can
see these pieces dropping down so here's
a piece dropping here's another piece
dropping and then in this big part here
these are the access patterns of of the
the ROM over time and you'll notice when
it's rendered this way you can see you
know over time there's just huge
sections
um like here in the middle that aren't
ever really red and there's a little bit
here in the beginning but over time very
little of it is used and that is also
visible here at the very bottom where we
graph out
over in that portion of Time how much of
the ROM was actually used in that
portion of time and you can see it stays
fairly consistent around five percent so
this is um
the partitioned aspect of it where you
know we we found that at any given
moment only a very little portion of the
ROM is actually used
so how do we get there
the
the beginning of playable quotes
um as Adam and I were talking about it
we weren't even sure if this was going
to work like we would talk to other
computer scientists they're like this is
never going to work you know there's
we'd come up with all these reasons why
it wouldn't work but to get started just
a brief comment
uh how many of you have heard of program
slicing
well a few people what we're doing is a
kind of program slicing but under
different constraints but it's
definitely related to that scholarly
tradition yeah
and so um
so what we did is Adam and I set aside
some time and we picked pie boy so this
pieboy emulator is actually really nice
it's a very clean code very easy to
understand and use
um really liked it and each of us took a
different approach to
exploring Pi boy but the idea was to
just monitor a gameplay and get a list
of all the bytes of the ROM that were
used so Adam used the Jupiter notebook
wrote a fancy plugin to you know Snoop
on all the different memory access
patterns I did a much more primitive
approach where I was actually like
editing the code manually to to do that
but the idea was to build a log out that
would allow us to make an allow list to
basically say you know we're going to
only allow these particular ranges in
the ROM to be used and then we each
separately modified our version of Pi
boy to have a plug-in that would check
so when it when the emulator would go to
read a portion of the ROM we would have
a hook to basically say like can you
read that portion of ROM or not
and the big aha moment for me was when
we were able to exchange our our allow
list with each other so we like
transmitted the allow list
um you know over the internet to each
other and we were each able to play a
quote that the other person had made and
I was like the big aha moment for me was
like it works you can actually play a
game where you strip out most of the ROM
and just with this allow list uh have a
playable game that you can have within
this tiny tiny constraint
um there were a few problems with this
in particular there was a a game I
wanted to to build a quote from and just
didn't work but we'd also wanted to make
something that worked online so we
switched to the Game Boy online project
and
um used that to build the same thing but
have it on a web page so that you didn't
have to have a particular version of any
software running as long as you had a
browser you could use that and the cool
thing about this is that we didn't even
have to modify the code we were able to
just monkey patch the existing code and
add our our capabilities on top of it so
here's a brief bit of code there's more
of course in the the Prototype or in the
implementation that we built but the
cool thing is there's this Niche proxy
function how many here have have used
this before
ah okay so this was something that I
really like it allows you to modify
existing JavaScript and what you see
here is that we've overridden the get
operations so when other code of the
code in this project goes to go read
from memory instead of it being read
from memory we hook into our existing or
hook into our own little function that
will check that allow list and um
and then you know if if that portion of
memory is part of the quote we will let
you go through otherwise we'll uh load
some code up that will handle that that
condition of like oh
this part of the quote isn't available
um and so by default we just reset but
we have a hook in there so that you can
decide what you want to happen and so uh
the cool thing about this is with that
that capability we didn't have to modify
the code at all and it's uh would have
been difficult to modify because it's
very like Compact and optimized for
Speed so having this ability was was was
really nice
so here's what it looks like let's go
and take a look at Tetris
um oh I want to load that one I'm going
to go and load this one here
um so this is what the quote looks like
again that's Tetris but if you look here
up on the screen here we just have a URL
so this is just a simple player the only
input is a URL and you'll notice it is a
URL to just an image that's the image
that is the quote so everything needed
to run that quote of Tetris is in this
image and you might be wondering how is
it in the image well if you turn your
head sideways you can see here eight BPP
stag zip
the way that we
um encode the game into the um
so
[Applause]
um this here is uh what it looks like
when we uh steganographically encode the
zip file containing the quote into the
image Adam played with the the contrast
and you can pop out these like little
different colors here
um and this is a technique that came
from the creature Creator in Spore it's
also used in the Pico 8 fantasy emulator
there's a bunch of different ways you
can join a zip file into an image but
this is the most durable so if you want
to share a quote over uh social media
like uh you know the like popular ones
like blue sky or Mastodon this will stay
um
this will
um this will keep all of the data so
that you can like see your friend will
post a a quote that they made and you
can just take that image and put it into
a player and it'll just work
so what's in a zip let's take a look so
the zip file contains five basic things
it has the copy of the original ROM but
with everything that's been masked out
it has a separate mask because you you
can't know whether you know a zero in
the that Mass DOT ROM was meant to be
zero or if it's one of the portions that
we we emptied out so we have a mask that
lets the the emulator tell whether the
uh that portion of the ROM is supposed
to you know supposed to be red or not
and then we have a Save State for the
emulator so the quote starts from a safe
state so from the moment in the game
where you want to to have that that
quote start
and then we also have a record of all
the controller presses so this is what
has that performative aspect where you
can see what was originally done in the
game
um those those button presses are read
from from this file here
and then finally we have some metadata
that we put in there just plain old text
and that's in there so that uh if
somebody was to find this and figure out
that it's uh steganographically encoded
in order to pull it out then it explains
what's in the in the quote what it's how
it works how to kind of recreate it so
um 100 years from now if people have
forgotten what quotes are but they run
across this the these files they'll be
able to you know extract out the the the
zip and see what's inside like if that
if you had to go get the data from the
GitHub code archive you could find
enough data there in order to bring
these quotes back to life
and then finally we've got a screenshot
but the cool thing is the screenshot's
already in the quote because it's that
PNG
um and that's the screenshot of the
moment that the quote started
if you want to read more you can go in
uh find this paper so um Adam and I uh
presented this at the foundations of
digital games conference earlier this
year we've got all the details in this
paper so that's that's that Joelle we've
only used like 14 minutes
there's more
so once we built out this work in
Prototype we realized there's a bunch of
different areas we want to go but we're
going to talk about these three here
today so
three of the areas that we've taken in
quotes into our how do everyday people
create and share playable quotes
how can you embed quotes into a a web
page and what new modes of communication
are available what are things that you
can do with quotes that you couldn't do
before so let's talk about some of those
so in terms of creating and sharing
quotes you can do this now if you go to
10mile.quote.games we have a working
prototype online
and this is what it looks like so the
way it works is I have this cool open
source game called tough this is what we
used when we were
experimenting with with building this
out
and what I can do here
is I can go and you know go to a portion
here and then I can hit record new quote
and um gesture up there oh yeah so it's
a little bit hard to see but while he's
playing it's trying to give him feedback
on how much of the ROM he's touched and
as he brings his character to different
rooms it's telling him he's always used
one percent or two percent of the ROM at
this point trying to give you feedback
on how heavy is your quote going to be
when you go to export it so I've gone
around and played a little bit I've
touched uh
2.2122 percent of the ROM I can stop
recording it takes a little while to
make it and here is a quote so now I
have this image file I can go share it
online
um I can also click play
and so now here I am it's showing my old
gameplay
and at any moment I can click here take
control and I can start playing around
in this so that's how you make a quote
and let's go and look at some of the
other things that we've made so here are
quotes that we've made
one of my favorite games is the Legend
of Zelda this is a game that my brother
and I really loved and this moment was
like really uh impressive to us I
remember we actually went and got graph
paper and copied down this this this
raccoon here but now I can click take
control and uh so now I can go and
explore around in the game but you'll
notice if I do something that wasn't
part of the of that original quote it
resets so I try to leave this map that
doesn't work I try to go over there that
doesn't work because I I didn't record
all the different ways that that link
was facing but um that is a playable
quote of that particular moment anything
else I should
talk about Adam
I don't remember go on
um so yeah so I think we we did oh there
is something yeah uh go back to one of
those quotes and and uh let's use the
quote viewer to unpack the zip and sort
of show all those pieces that we talked
about oh right yeah so here's the quote
player and you'll notice up here it says
you know slash play and if I type view
and
there so this is the visualization of
this um this quote so the code here will
take this image give you a view of the
the sliced ROM
here's the ROM validity mask
here is the text that we put in the
readme
and the Remake has stuff like the hash
of the original game so if you find a
quote later you're like but which
version of Zelda this come from it's
like well we're not giving you the whole
game but we will give you some metadata
about the thing that came from so you
can sort of verify its source
and then here are all the button presses
that we we did so that is how you can
create and share a quote with 10 mile
similarly how do you embed a quote so
who here knows about web components
all right well for those of you who
haven't used web components it's a cool
thing where you can make your own HTML
tags so if you want to bring back blink
or Marquee you can do that
uh similarly if you want to use a quote
uh maybe in an essay that you're writing
about you know your favorite game or
your collection of favorite games you
can now embed the web component and it's
just like using normal HTML you can put
in the source here a little PNG of of
that that quote and you can say that say
whether you want to have controls
whether you want it to autoplay do all
that kind of stuff
one extra thing about that is that that
element is scriptable so if you want to
do things
[Music]
no I should just we'll just show the
next demo yeah we'll highlight the
scriptability of our new little
embeddable component
so
um the next demo is showing
a things you can do with quotes that you
couldn't do before so um this here is a
guided tour of the Gameboy game Metroid
2. and it's a a Google Maps style
interface
um so here what you see is a map of the
Metroid 2 game
and uh I'm going to zoom in here
we worked with a speedrunner who went
through and recorded quotes of all these
different key moments in Metroid
and so I can click on any moment here
here's a quote but here's something that
you couldn't do before if I click on
Trace
down in the corner if you look over here
you can see it played but what is this
what's going on here
let me zoom in like six days ago
there we go so as
[Applause]
so yeah now you can see the uh the
actual live play through and um because
it is an emulator
um that we're running you can pull out
the X and Y coordinates of where Samus
is in the game and render it on a map
like you see there this is also online
you can go to
m2.quote.games and experiment with this
yourself
um and so that's another aspect part of
how that works is uh the quote was
embedded using a web component but then
some JavaScript was attached that then
interfaced with this this this map here
that you see on the screen
so many of you might be thinking like
this is cool uh Game Boy
but uh you know what about modern games
uh what about modern stuff like um what
about modern stuff Adam
okay we we did this you know it plays
eight bit games from the 90s but but can
it do like PC games we gotta be careful
when you say PC games because like would
you be happy with me making playable
quotes
for the IBM PC like in terms of
technical specs in terms of its mass
storage or memory it's like pretty
similar I mean ROM is not a hard disk
but we'll get into that later but I
think the bigger source of challenge is
going to be sort of it's it's just a
matter of numerical scaling right hard
drives are only a hundred thousand times
bigger memory is only a million times
bigger
um the amount of memory you can touch
each second is only you know 10 million
times bigger
uh but but let's think through what it
would take to to do this in the future
and I will say at the time that we
submitted our talk proposal here
we only knew how to do Game Boy and we
thought well we'll give a talk on that
and then so a lot of this stuff is stuff
we come up with in in the intervening
time since submitting The Proposal
so if you think of before we had this
book metaphor for quoting uh the ROM is
like a fixed book and you want certain
pages of ROM but to quote software off
of like hard drive this is like you want
to quote from a book that people are
constantly writing into and how you read
the book is changing how the book is
being written and you still want to make
a quote of it so that's
searched the metaphor a bit but I guess
these days it's kind of convenient that
like a hard drive is really just another
memory chip so that's a consolation
prize
another thing is that the software you
might want to quote like it's not even
on the hard drive it's it's an app that
somebody dynamically downloaded it's
it's a chunk of code that was emitted by
a just-in-time compiler or uh is part of
a web page that loaded after the
computer booted up so the software is
not on the hard drive to start but
but if that software ran on your CPU it
must have been in memory at least for a
little bit at some point so it's all
pointing back to memory here
another thing that's different when you
try to go beyond Game Boy is like we
don't want to just quote the game
there's little bits of game States
spread across this whole stack here
um think about uh modern games use uh
shaders or they might use the the GPU to
accelerate their their particle system
so there's game State spread across many
layers of hardware and software so when
we want to figure out what data is
needed anything at any of these layers
could be reading and writing the data we
need
is there some audio feedback
okay
um
but I don't know ultimately at least in
the emulator or the virtual machine the
state of all these different things is
it's somewhere in memory
but the um the speed at which you can
access memory is just absurd you know
your modern computer that does two
billion things per second each one of
those two billion things that those
instructions were being fetched from my
memory probably a cache but but from a
memory executing each one of those
instructions might touch multiple places
in memory each one of those each one of
those separate memory access things
could be the first one that is the one
to go out of bounds in the quote that we
might need to add to our allow list so
we've got to sort of put our code for
logging in the innermost Loop of like
within a single machine instruction and
worse than that it's not just the
processor that can read and write memory
that like the hard disk can say hey I
want to do some direct memory access so
there's memory transactions coming in
from all over all the time moving tons
of memory around and the software we
might want to modify like a PC virtual
machine some of these things like
struggle to run the virtual machines
already let alone us adding
instrumentations that's going to slow
them way down so it's like how is it
that modern processors are even able to
implement a memory protection well they
have like dedicated Hardware memory
management units with things like a
translation look aside buffer to
accelerate these memory allow list
checks and we certainly don't have
access to that in JavaScript so
going Beyond Game Boy my lab is looking
at how we're going to do this for N64
and some other things but there's
there's a lot of ground to cover
so what have you got
so
so at this point this is sort of how
Adam and I feel we're like the two
spiders and we're thinking like well uh
you know what we have so far feels a bit
like that web but if we can pull it off
we'll uh eat like kings
um so what have you gotten working so
far in the lab
um oh yeah we've done the N64 stuff but
um
but I really want to get these PC games
working do you know of any like
web-based emulators for for PCs has
anybody here heard about uh the v86
project
all right
so uh tell us about v86
um okay we looked into this one I guess
in order to get nice high performance
able to run things like Windows 95 in
the browser it's written in Rust and
that rust code dynamically generates
more webassembly code on the Fly it's
it's pretty complicated it's pretty
interesting but there's a lot of cool
demos that are built on it
um what's a little bit tricky is that
some of our monkey patching tricks that
we were able to do for JavaScript
because this thing is written in a
compiled language we can't just
dynamically substitute our own
implementation of an array or something
like that and on top of that if we could
this thing is constantly writing more
and more code as it executes so we'd
have to like instrument the code that's
being generated on the Fly
oh it's just a small amount of
programming right
uh okay you wanted me to do
quotes of PC games
you're not gonna like this demo look
it's a PC I'm running Windows and
there's there's a game but but it's
gonna work
okay it boots nice and quickly you could
down here want to draw your attention to
this is a visualization of
the oops how do I zoom in I think my
keys are being trapped by that thing
there's little m's in here for the parts
of physical memory that we've read
during Windows boot and down here when
Windows booted from a floppy Drive image
you can see it didn't touch all the
floppy Drive sectors so there's parts of
the disk that were not used that's sort
of the thing that's
both of those are playing the role of a
ROM here uh I can have I can sort of
reset my statistics here to say like
well now that we've booted how much
memory is Windows touching just to sit
here rendering at the desktop and this
is what the Windows desktop used to look
like and it's not much memory so I'm
gonna go turn on Mouse lock for a second
I'm gonna I'm gonna launch a PC game
reversee
we're gonna like play a few moments of
it you can see I'm starting to touch a
little bit more memory I actually had to
touch a little bit of disk because you
know reversee.exe had to be like loaded
from the floppy
uh and I'll quit back to the desktop
and now I'm going to enter this uh sort
of simulated quote playback mode so it
says if we were to make a quote at that
point we would have only brought in
about
the a quarter of a megabyte so now when
I interact I'm only allowed to touch
things that were on my allow list so
hopefully I should be able to launch
reversi again and make similar moves I
should be able to quit but if I try to
run
trustynnotepad.exe so I can do some some
programming
if I actually double click it
unceremoniously down here it says disk
Out of Bounds at sector 86 and or I
could have done something different like
access one of these menus that I hadn't
used before and it would have said
memory Out of Bounds at some particular
page so we've got the the hardest part
of quoting working for a PC emulator
running x86
um and lots of stuff targets x86 sorry
it's only the 32-bit version for now but
we'll work on that eventually
um one of the things that I like about
this is that we were actually able to do
this without touching the rust code of
the project
um there's this project called binarian
a webassembly compiler tool chain and
one of it's just command line flags that
it supports off the shelf is this
instrument memory pass that will rewrite
an existing webassembly binary to before
every memory access call out to some
other function which we Implement in
JavaScript so it's kind of fun that like
beneath the lowest level of individual
machine instructions is the fluffy high
level JavaScript they are sort of a
strange loot across scales if you will
so that's great Adam but uh but can I
run Doom
foreign
so the calling a JavaScript function
inside of a machine instruction uh
with the demo system I just showed you
no that would not be suitable for
running Doom like the virtual machine
boots it's just super slow but by
running that super slow demo we got a
sense of what actually takes the time
and we actually got some major speed UPS
so I'm going to show you this other demo
here of our Advanced instrumentation
demo
oh look Doom is running nice smooth I
don't know exactly what the frame rate
is depends on whether I'm plugged in
here but there's so much memory in this
larger virtual machine that I can't just
show you individual pages but down here
it's a little bit hard to see we have a
little webgl canvas showing one pixel
for each four kilobyte page
um and saying like when is the first
time that we've accessed that memory so
we're doing our memory tracking
fast enough that you don't feel it in
gameplay we're about maybe 2X or it's
maybe what's it called 2x lower than the
the original thing but because the CPU
does more than just memory accesses it's
you don't actually notice it and just
like I can press buttons it really is
running this it's not just a Canon video
there and I can reset the statistics
here
um oh let me
show you just one cool thing
reset these pay attention down here when
Doom starts up it's going to go read
lots of memory as it sort of zeros out
all the stuff it's going to use so
you'll see
oh you saw it like access all that
memory wallets
zeroing out the memory it's going to use
during gameplay so it is really doing
that that tracking
um
I would love to give you lots of details
on how this part actually worked but
it's kind of complicated and we just
sort of got it working like super
recently if you want to learn more about
the the general technique we're using
which we're calling like just in time
binary instrumentation there was an
excellent talk at Defcon a couple years
ago the title hacking webassembly games
with binary instrumentation
um the big idea here is that we need to
generate code that runs quickly but we
need the code generator itself to run
extremely quickly because that compiler
is running it's competing for my host
CPU with the virtual machine itself
um so the code is a little bit messy but
you can learn more there
so that's where we are now there's a lot
of territory to be explored and uh we'd
love help so if any of the things that
you see here on the screen look
interesting to you we love to talk with
uh ux designers that can help us teach
users how to create and edit quotes if
you're a software developer of course we
love uh to see quotes in more areas like
qemu or Mame or other similar systems
just opening up this capability to more
areas and then if you're a writer if you
want to write about your favorite games
we'd love to have you include a quote
into that that writing
and then lastly just want to point out
that uh it's more than just me and Adam
there's a whole team behind us including
people like sanctum who've gone through
and the sanctum is the the speed Runner
and then the other folks that you see
here are the other collaborators that
we've had on this so just want to make
sure that we give a shout out to them
but also thank you all for uh for
watching and um and yeah that's that is
playable quotes thank you very much
[Applause]